ilaria baldwin ellaria
baldwin is alec baldwin's wife i guess
she's something of a social media star
herself
uh his wife got caught pretending to be
spanish
for years and years and years ilaria
baldwin
uh pretended to be spanish she's not
really illaria she's hillary
she didn't she didn't grow up with you
know exclusively speaking spanish or
anything like that she grew up in
america
and she speaks english she got caught
because people
noticed that her accent would change
depending on what interview she was
giving
so she was on an nbc show and she she
somehow couldn't remember the english
award the for a cucumber
we have very few ingredients we have
tomatoes we have um
cucumber cucumbers we have um red pepper
okay we have um what is uh how you say
how you say any english uh oh a cucumber
right
so okay wow this woman she doesn't speak
english very well but she's trying
that's good but then
then you hear another interview of her
and her english is is perfectly fine
it's not easy and i think part of it is
that i'm in shape before i have a baby
and then i stay active when i'm pregnant
and that's
i'm not trying to stay then i'm just
trying to keep my circulation going and
stretching and keep my muscle tone up
and then when i have the baby i've been
so lucky to have pretty good
labor and delivery so then i can kind of
hit the road right outdoors
so elaria baldwin is like that person
who studies abroad
for a semester in college in in england
for instance and then comes back and
says like why right there governor now
you're going to the pub later tonight
for a point yeah
hey i want some more you want some more
you know
and i actually i know a person who did
this and it was it's very strange i mean
it is
clearly something has gone a little a
little awry in their psychology
there was a gal that i knew who she went
to
london for like a month or less and she
came back and had the most
preposterous fake british accent i've
ever
ever heard and actually a friend of mine
who's from the uk uh
asked we said oh where did you live in
the uk he doesn't have an accent by the
way
and she said oh you know in london yeah
we're in london well you know like
on the next to the tube or whatever you
know next to the pub
uh so it's it's this is very sad and
embarrassing and uh so
illario baldwin uh you know took her
licks and kind of
you know just tried to disappear for a
little bit so now she's back and she's
saying
that actually she is trans cultural and
this is perfectly good she's culturally
fluid she says
when you are multi whatever multi
everyone's multi now we all contain
multitudes
it can feel hard to belong you're
constantly going back and forth trying
to be more this or more that you feel
you have to explain
why you are the way you are trying to
fit into a world of labels where there
might not be one that perfectly defines
you you will never quite fit in because
of the other parts of you
shape and influence all your parts we
need to normalize the fact that we're
all unique
our culture our languages sexual
orientations religions
political beliefs are allowed to be
fluid
no two of us are completely alive got to
be fluid we're all fluid these days
nothing's fixed nothing's said
you see this reflected in language by
the way people no longer state plain
facts
they they no longer say this is true
they'll say i think this is true then it
became i believe this is true then it
became i feel
like this is true because i feel like is
unfalsifiable you can't have an argument
with someone who feels
like because they're not making a truth
claim they're just
talking about their feels man and i know
this seems subtle and
i i some people might say i'm reading
too much into it but i don't think i am
so
michael you're just talking about
semantics well semantics means meaning
right i mean this is this is the premise
of my book speechless
i think this is the most important tool
that has reshaped our culture and these
things really do matter no one wants to
be pinned down on anything
everyone's a pan buy trans fluid
whatever
you know nobody nobody is the plain old
thing that they say that they are
yo hey you stop right there before you
click don't click
you gotta ring the bell you gotta
subscribe then you will hopefully get
the notifications though sometimes big
tech doesn't want
our followers to get the notifications
you can watch this whole episode it's
called save us florida man
uh you can also get it on apple podcast
spotify google play stitcher myspace
xanga livejournal aol instant messenger
you can also order my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
thank you to everyone who made it a
number one national bestseller we really
appreciate that
we really appreciate the new york times
too for snubbing us and continuing to
sell a lot of books for us we really
really appreciate that thank you to all
of you have read leave a comment we'll
see you next time